all right it's not going to be a
surprise when the games get started
there will be some form of protesting
during the national anthem i think the
nfl's bigger question for now is will
there be a point this season where
players refuse to play games because of
social justice issues john mara giants
co-owner meeting with reporters via
video conference yesterday also
addressed his thoughts on where things
currently stand as it relates to players
protesting during the anthem here he is
you know my preference is that everybody
stand but um if you
decide in your conscience that um
you think taking a knee is the right
thing to do i'm going to support your
right to do that because i believe in
the first amendment and i believe in the
right of
people including especially players i
understand the fact and accept the fact
that that's not going to be
unnecessarily popular with certain
segments of our of our fan base but i
think it's the right thing to do
it's come a long way in three years now
look let me say two things first of all
i'd rather he not articulate his own
preference because for any player who's
in the process of searching his heart
and soul to come up with a decision he's
now aware
of the thumb
that the owner would put on the scale to
tip it towards standing for the anthem i
think every player should be encouraged
to make their own decision
and my preference is that you do what
you think is right not my preferences
that you stand i think that to truly
respect the rights of the players to
protest and to truly reflect what the
nfl has been trying to say through
commissioner roger goodell every owner
should be saying these players need to
make their own decisions however he
mentioned the reaction and here's what
he said back in 2017 when this issue
really was taking off in all my years
being in the league i never received
more emotional mail from people than i
did about that issue of players kneeling
during the national anthem if any of
your players ever do that
we are never coming to another giants
game it wasn't one or two letters it was
a lot it's an emotional emotional issue
for a lot of people more so than any
other issue i've run into all the more
reason for him not to state his own
preference all the more reason for him
to make it make sure that anyone out
there who would be ready to send more
letters i didn't know anybody sent
letters anymore but anyone that would be
ready to send letters ready to huff and
puff and maybe blow the house in
part of the obligation of the owners is
to truly have their players backs and i
don't think it's enough shireen to say
hey i've got your back you've got to
stand up to the bullies you've got to
stand up to the haters you've got to
stand up to the fans who are going to
say i'm never coming to a game again and
say fine we don't want your business if
you don't understand these players have
the right to protest to bring awareness
to an important societal issue that has
gone on long enough that's what they
need to be willing to do when owners
start doing that
that's when players will start believing
that owners truly have their backs
mike you've used the line many times and
it's great of trying to thread the
needle and we know how difficult that is
if you've ever tried to thread the
needle and that's what some of these
owners are trying to do and john mara
said more than jerry jones has said uh
but he still left some doubt there of i
would prefer for you to stand and you
know
things have changed so much he was one
of the guys john mara was who who had
the nfl
write a policy on the anthem which
obviously didn't go over well with the
players and after all the backlash it
was kind of thrown out but things have
really changed not over the last two
years or three years or whatever but
things have changed over the last few
months they've changed a lot and and i
think owners have to realize and a lot
of them have and coaches too we saw it
with bill o'brien saying i'll kneel with
their pl with our players if they if
they want to kneel and and so things
have changed so much that that's where
we are that that owners and coaches have
to come out and totally back their
players at this point sponsors aren't
going to pull out they would look much
worse if they pulled out at this point
so that's not even a consideration
anymore maybe it was in 2016 when colin
kaepernick first started kneeling
that's not an issue now fans saying i'm
not going to watch your games anymore
i'm going to burn your jerseys i'm not
going to get fans aren't going to games
anyway who cares they're still going to
watch let's be honest they might say
they're not going to watch they're still
going to watch the nfl is still going to
be the number one thing on tv regardless
of what happens here
but owners have to are going to have to
make a choice it's going to be
are you going to continue to to side
with trump are you going to side with
your players and frankly that's that's
what it is at this point it it it's that
decision that they're going to have to
make and jerry jones and and john mayer
right in the middle of that
jerry jones last addressed his position
on the anthem issue his effort to thread
the needle by fashioning a compromise
where players would stand during the
anthem but find some other way to
protest it's been a long 10 days and a
lot's happened in between last friday
when he appeared yet again on 105.3 the
fan in dallas wasn't asked about it even
though i think the world changed
dramatically the sports world
particularly from tuesday to friday of
last week then came tuesday of this week
wasn't asked about it again i don't know
this but i believe that the folks at the
flagship station for the dallas cowboy
broadcast have been told ixnay on the
anthem questions
uh i wonder if though he's going to want
to address it now we've seen dak
prescott yesterday there were more
comments suggesting i think it was
tyrone crawford saying that players have
the green light to protest when i see
these i i still i since it's coming from
the players and not from ownership
part of me is skeptical
that there's been this
this opening of the floodgates where
they've been told do whatever you want
sorry forget everything that we've said
and done over the last three years we've
had an organic personality change and
we're now going to let you protest i
think that this idea that they've got a
green light to protest is all part of
the effort to coax them to stand for the
anthem and then find some other platform
for protesting
well you go back to to last year when
they got when they acquired michael
bennett and they acquired robert quinn
and both in trades and both of those
guys ended up standing for the national
anthem
which they had not done before
previously they had both protested in
the past but how did the cowboys get
them to do that well they gave them
contractual things that led them to
stand for the anthem now michael bennett
wandered with a
cup of water in the background he didn't
stand with toes on his line toes on the
line i'm sure as jerry jones would have
appreciated but he certainly stood for
the anthem he didn't sit he didn't do he
didn't stay in the locker room he didn't
do all those things and the cowboys are
one of the only teams in the nfl who
have never had a player protest during
the anthem jerry jones has always found
a way to make that happen i just think
it's going to be much harder this year
to find a way to make that happen
because don terry poe has already been
one who's come out and said
i don't care what my teammates do i'm
going to kneel for the national anthem
so how he fixes all this i don't know
but i i'm going to be i'll be more
surprised that the if the cowboys don't
have a player protest than llb that
adrian peterson got released today
the way tyrone crawford explained it
yesterday he said that they want to do
something that will be big they want to
do something that will be conspicuous
and it just makes me wonder
is there something else in the works and
is this part of you know did jerry come
up with something where he said hey guys
how about doing this instead of kneeling
during the anthem and explaining to them
look the kneeling during the anthem gets
a lot of people upset they don't
understand let's come up with a
different way to get our point across
that isn't diluted by that 30 of society
that's going to lose their minds
whenever someone takes a knee so i just
feel like there's something percolating
there's something happening
and the fact that it's coming from the
players makes me feel that that they're
trying to set the stage for whatever
ultimately is done
is something the players came up with
not something that jerry jones
cajoled them into coming up with the way
that he'll throw his arm around a guy
just as it's time to work out a contract
and get him to see it jerry jones way
and to understand that
jerry jones way and the player's way are
the same way one last point on this
though and this is something that i've
mentioned twice this week and as we get
closer and closer to next thursday night
this is something we all need to
understand it's something the nfl and
its teams need to understand
protest during the anthem
are going to take a back seat to the
reaction by
that segment of society that is going to
be very upset
shireen when they see on the rear
bumpers of the helmets the names of
victims of police violence and systemic
racism that is going to be a very
controversial thing once people
understand that it's coming and you know
we're talking to a very
small niche audience out of the greater
scope of people who would turn on a
football game you know over the course
of a year how many millions will watch a
game you have 120 million plus watch the
super bowl there are millions of fans
out there that aren't paying any
attention to any of the run-up to the
season they'll turn on the games when
the games start they're going to see the
close-ups they're going to see names
like george floyd brianna taylor etc
and uh there's going to be a reaction
and it's going to be a significant
reaction and it may go all the way up to
the white house when it's time for
people to start tweeting their reaction
to this effort and and so i think at a
time when the nfl needs to be concerned
about what happens during the anthem
they need to spend some time being
concerned about the blowback to the
names on the back of the helmets because
it's coming
it is coming and and all those things
are coming in the end zones we didn't
even talk about the enzos when people
see the end zones i don't think they
realize what those end zones are going
to say and there are going to be people
who are going to be upset even though it
says in racism in one end zone i i just
think that that is going to upsets a
small segment of the population and
they're going to say again i'm going to
turn off the nfl i'm never watching a
game again i didn't watch the game and
yet i the the vast majority of people
are still going to watch the nfl i mean
we we see it every year you know 2016
when colin kaepernick first started
protesting during the anthem i'm never
watching another nfl game and the
ratings have just continued to climb so
until the ratings start to decline
i don't think the nfl is going to have a
great concern about this there will be
some
minority of owners including jerry jones
who probably will and try to work out
some compromise
which he is he is great at that as you
pointed out he does it in so many ways
in so many different facets of his
organization uh but he's done that but
the vast majority of people are still
going to watch the nfl and the ratings
are going to continue to climb and until
they don't i don't think the nfl as a
whole is going to worry about this about
what other people think and tweet and
say
but here's the thing in 2016 the ratings
did drop because of a very hotly
contested presidential election the nfl
believed in 2017 the ratings would
rebound they didn't in 2017 and there
are some who believe that one of the
issues was the anthem protest that some
of the people who claimed they were done
with the nfl at least for this year made
good on that promise and and throughout
the colin kaepernick collusion case
against the nfl one of the themes that
mark garrigus and his legal team was
pursuing was this idea that there was an
equal
percentage on each side of the issue
that felt very strongly about it and
that for whatever reason the nfl chose
to cater to the percentage that was
huffing and puffing about anthem
protests what's going on now is the
owners recognize that if they align with
that crowd they're potentially going to
have
wildcat strikes that play out and games
are going to be missed and time when
they're worried about the pandemic they
got to worry about players walking out
and so the owners and whether it's
business reasons or whether they just
finally realize it's the right thing to
do i feel like they are starting to
balance it out and that's what's
resulting in the effort to thread the
needle because it's not enough to be
heavy-handed anymore it's not good
enough to say we're going to stand for
the anthem no matter what other players
on other teams do you have to find a way
to show your players that you truly are
behind them and i think for some of the
owners it's been a little clumsy and
like i said earlier i want owners to
come out and say we've got our players
backs and show it by standing up to
those who are trying to bully the nfl
and its players into not protesting
whether it's during the anthem whether
it's with the names on the helmets
whether it's the words at the back of
the end zones whatever it is it's going
to get people upset and get them to rant
and rave the owners need to be willing
to stand up and say to those people take
your business elsewhere
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports